[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream our 88th
is that correct dr heing that is correct
dr weinstein i am dr brett weinstein and
we have uh
many things in store for you today this
is obviously not the usual day
that we do live streams but uh anyway
thank you for
joining us let us start with some
announcements
yeah well first of all we we will be uh
starting once we get through the
announcements and the ads for today
by talking a little bit about why we
missed saturday
and then we're going to dedicate much of
today's episode
to a discussion of food which is in line
with
our discussion of chapter five of our
forthcoming book a hundred gatherers
guide to the 21st century so we'll be
beginning that discussion
with a fairly long excerpt from that
chapter and then talking about some of
the other
um some other pieces of the scientific
literature that uh are
are emerging around diets and how we
could all be
helping ourselves by by eating in
uh in a better way to be clear we will
not be providing
food we will just be talking about it we
will not be no nor can we do like
scratch and sniff videos or nothing like
that not yet
no i think that's for the best honestly
yeah i could see how that could go wrong
i do i can too yeah so um today
as um has been well i guess we've only
done it once so far but we are streaming
on both youtube and odyssey
uh we are not going to drop the youtube
stream but we encourage you to go
over to the odyssey stream if um
if you are on youtube uh that is that is
where we are going to be
moving uh as much of our content uh as
as as soon as possible as we think makes
sense
uh we have a new q a system so we'll be
doing this for
something between an hour and two hours
we'll take a 15-minute break and then
we'll come back with
live q a and you can ask
questions by going to
darkhorsesubmissions.com
and the q a system should be
self-explanatory it was very glitchy
last time for which we apologize and we
think
we think those problems are fixed now
but please do not hesitate to
email ourmod darkhorsemoderator
gmail.com
if it's if it's acting glitchy on you we
should change that to darkhorse
dominance
and submissions just so we're like
equally welcoming
yeah yeah i suppose we should
um and just just a reminder that you
know we prioritize
answering questions based on what we
think is most interesting
the monetary value of the questions uh
in the second half to some degree the
order in which they come in
uh there's now a feature where and you
can um you can actually upvote questions
that's a tiny
a tiny factor in in whether or not we
look at the questions
um so there's no guarantee that your
question will get answered if you do um
submit one on that site but
um but we will we will see them all we
encourage you to join our patreons uh
to next sunday is our private q a for
this month which you can access
at my patreon and um bret has monthly
conversations as well you can also
access the discord server there
and we've got uh these goliath t-shirts
which are um
selling like you know not so much hot
cakes but like goliath t-shirts
uh at uh at store.darkhorsepodcast.org
now event now many things are available
in short sleeve as well
and before we got to the ads there were
two things that happened this week
uh that aren't directly about what we're
going to be doing today that we wanted
to mention you have an
awesome essay out in unheard and also a
terrific conversation
with tesla right here on the dartmouth
yes actually zach could you
show the
uh this is the thumbnail for the tesla
conversation tess laurie is with the
bird group
uh the british uh iremechton
group she is a data analyst and she and
i sat down
and talked about among other things the
effect of the study that has been
questioned most prominently in the
guardian we talked about what the effect
on the meta-analysis that she had been
a second author on was if you simply
eliminate that study and recalculate and
it's fascinating so for all of those
including the guardian i think said
something remarkable preposterous
and obnoxious about the elimination of
that study
somehow reversing the conclusion which
it absolutely does not
and if you want to see what happens to
the study
in actuality you can just watch tess
remove the study and click recalculate
well it you know the problem may be that
as you point out in that conversation
i've not finished listening to it yet
but as you point out in the conversation
with tess lari
people have been invoking garbage and
garbage out with regard to meta-analysis
and certainly if all of what you put
into it was garbage then what you would
get out was garbage
but if one thing that you put in is
garbage there's a good chance that you
can pull it
and get a get a result that's maybe even
stronger than what you had before which
is of course
one of the results that we see with that
meta-analysis but with regard to
journalism
uh it seems like geigo may be applying
that with regard to that guardian
article
speaking of garbage the guardian article
which reached a demonstrably false
conclusion
uh is uh is clearly garbage now what the
state of the study that had to be
removed is
is unclear there are reasons to uh be
concerned about it
and it's not clear what what is causal
there so
you know i remain agnostic as to what
the meaning
of the the worrisome bits in in that
study are but
nonetheless the ability to remove it is
actually
a strong argument in favor of
meta-analysis because the point is the
method simply tells you how it should
change your impression of in this case
the utility of ivermectin yep okay
and then you also wanted to talk speak
to uh this
yeah actually please let me save this
until after our ads and announcements
there's a little more to say about it
okay um sure so let's we have we have
two ads
uh today so zach uh if you want to
there we go this week's show is
sponsored in part by elform
a company that is making absolutely
terrific custom sofas
what makes a sofa terrific though well
in this case you can customize your size
layout and materials easily
for a fraction of the cost of
traditional stores you pick your fabric
color of both the sofa and the legs the
shape to fit your home and needs
perfectly they do arm chairs and love
seats all the way up to eight seat
sectionals
and you can start small and buy more
seats later on
which is which is an interesting uh i
think fairly novel thing in sofas
without needing to get a whole new sofa
all from sofas are delivered directly to
your home with fast free shipping
in the past it would take weeks or even
months to arrive and you would need
someone to come and assemble it at your
home
all form takes usually less than a week
to arrive and you can assemble it
yourself no tools needed
we ended up with a beautiful sectional
all-form sofa in whiskey leather
although to us it reminds us a bit more
of caramel than whiskey
and it's you know we we anticipated
in advance that we would disagree as to
whether or not we wanted
yet another piece of leather furniture
uh i i thought
no way no how but this leather is so
beautiful
and we ended up going with leather and
not only is it beautiful but it's also
warm
you know in the way that most a lot of
leather furniture is very cold to the
touch and this is not
it's durable and it's not in bachelor
black it's it's that well we've never
we've never done that we never we've
never had black leather but um
so the four of us and um and the dog and
one or one or more of our cats pile onto
it watch and watch movies some evenings
and it looks gorgeous
and it's incredibly inviting and
comfortable to watch a movie get some
work done the computer read a book
take a nap and if you order one and
don't like it you have 100 days to say
actually no thank you
and they'll um that's more than three
months to ask for a full refund they'll
pick it up for free
and they offer a forever warranty
literally forever
to find your perfect sofa check out
allforum.com
darkhorse all form is offering 20 off
all orders for our listeners at
allform.com
darkhorse all right now on to
expressvpn a few decades ago private
citizens used to be largely that
private but what changed the internet
think about everything you've browsed
searched for or watched or tweeted
now imagine all of that data being
crawled through collected and aggregated
by third parties into a permanent public
record
your record having your private life
exposed for others to see was once
something only celebrities worried about
but in an era where everyone is online
everyone is a public figure to keep my
data private i go online with expressvpn
did you know that there are hundreds of
data brokers out there whose sole
business is to buy and sell your data
the worst part is they don't have to
tell you who they're selling it to or
get your consent
one of these data points is your ip
address data harvesters use your ip to
uniquely identify you and your location
but with expressvpn your connection gets
rerouted through an encrypted server
and your ip address is maxed at masked
masked every time i turn on expressvpn
i'm given a random ip address shared by
other expressvpn customers that makes it
more difficult for third parties to
identify me and harvest my data and the
best part is how
easy it is to use no matter what device
you're on
phone laptop smart tv all you do is tap
one button and you get connected and you
have very fast connections
so if like me you believe that your data
is your business
secure yourself with the number one
rated vpn on the market ex
visit expressvpn.com
darkhorse and get three extra months
free
that's expressvpn.com
darkhorse go to expressvpn.com
darkhorse to learn more
[Music]
all right you wanted to say a few things
about um
this essay that was solicited right that
you were invited we have one more thing
one more thing that we have to say about
why we weren't uh
i thought that was going to be next save
it next okay so yes let's uh let's go to
this essay
um so zach you want to put up the
so i published this essay in response to
unheard's query to me about how the
world might
for those who are just listening ah yes
those of you who are just listening
um unheard is a british magazine and
they
asked me to write a piece on how the
world might end
which is a question i've thought about
many times in a number of different ways
and i
wrote one the title of this one is
how the sun could wipe us out and it is
on
an important question that is known
to many but not widely discussed
something
i've been focused on since i first came
to understand the jeopardy
that it puts us on earth too
and the simple form of this is
that a burst of plasma coming from the
sun
electromagnetically charged if it hits
the earth
and is oriented just so can induce
massive currents
in earth-bound electrical architecture
and that can have
huge effects on things like our
electrical grid
and so this essay is about what might
flow from such an event
and the likelihood of such an event uh
occurring
and i'm hoping that you will check it
out i was planning to read
the first paragraph
um here it is
okay so it starts the world began to end
on the 12th of may 2024
though another 309 years would pass
before our species finally went extinct
the apocalypse was not the result of one
thing unless that one thing was that we
repeatedly
ignored signs that industrial
civilization had become incredibly
fragile
even as it grew more powerful but our
end very definitely had a trigger
a burst of charged plasma from the sun
caused the sudden simultaneous collapse
of numerous electrical grids across the
world
setting in motion a cascade of
devastating failures from which humanity
would never recover now
i will say i spooked myself in writing
this because it almost wrote itself
it is not that hard to see where the
fragility in our system
lurks even as the system is incredibly
powerful under normal circumstances
i will also say that interestingly i
wrote this
i finished it i guess a couple of weeks
ago and
finalized it last week and then
on the 15th and 17th
the sun threw off two massive
uh coronal ejections um
they happened to go in the opposite
direction
they went from where the earth is at the
moment yeah we are on the
side where the earth is during the
northern summer
and they were flung off in the direction
of where the earth is
in the northern winter they had it been
december
uh we would have been affected by them
we would
probably or possibly have been affected
the thing that's hard to calculate about
about this is that the sun throws these
things off with some regularity there is
a cycle
a solar cycle which we are um
nearing the apex of it will peak it is
it is not precisely predictable but it
will peak somewhere 20 24 20 25 12 13
your cycle is 11 years ago okay
um and so we are just beginning to pick
up solar
activity so this came very early uh
before the solar maximum
but in general when the uh earth
when the sun throws these things off
they're thrown off
in effectively a random direction and we
don't
tend to be where they are so they don't
affect us
it's not out to get us right every so
often we are
in the path and then there's a question
about the orientation
of the uh ejection as it hits us and
that affects whether or not it will
uh impact earthly technology
um so anyway there's a lot of uh
unknowns and uncertainties we never know
when these things are coming we never
know what direction they're going to go
and we never know whether they'll be
oriented in such a way as to cause a big
problem
or no problem but the most important
thing
is that the last time a really big one
of these things hit us
was 1859 right that happens to be
a year a number of things happen most
important to us is the publication of
the origin of species by darwin that
tells you how long ago this was
and it did have impacts it had impacts
on
the precursor to our electric grid it
had
impacts on the telegraph system it
induced currents in the wires it shocked
a number of tele
telegraph operators literally and
metaphorically
yes it literally shocked telegraph
operators who were touching
this device connected to these wires in
which suddenly massive currents were
flowing unpredictably
interestingly some were able to send
messages even though the system was
not powered because the power had been
induced from the outside
apparently buildings were set on fire
but in any case the point is
that same storm hitting us today would
have a very different impact because in
the period between 1859 and now the grid
has gone from
an exotic mechanism for sending
important messages over long distances
to something that
virtually everything we use depends on
the electrical grid
and what's more the way the electrical
rate is structured
um causes these effects uh to
um to spiral out of control so anyway i
would have you
look at that essay you might also look
into uh there's a piece on youtube
called the solar kill shot
um which describes exactly why
um not by me um i i
just saw it after my piece came out
somebody pointed me to it i had actually
not been
that's one of these things you're never
uh
made aware of these storms and in this
case because they were flung off in a
direction where the earth wasn't it's an
academic question at some level but
it does tell you something about the the
size of these risks and
the punchline to this story is
we are gambling we have been for
many decades we are gambling that we
will not have a major
catastrophic unrecoverable failure of
the grid
and we've gotten away with it so far but
we're living on borrowed time
and now would be the time to address it
right
if this is an addressable problem it
does not require us to confront some
massive
economic power that needs us to remain
vulnerable nobody on earth needs us to
remain vulnerable this is a problem we
could solve without anybody
even noticing the amount of money that
would need to be spent to do it
so there's no conflict of interest but
there is uh political apathy with regard
to
fixing the problem yes i think
unfortunately there's no
there's no fortunately there's no force
opposing or fixing it as far as i know
but there is also very little incentive
right to go after
it because because since most people are
unaware of the hazard
uh the creditors probably don't get
reelected on uh on say on
protecting and fixing this system right
right all right anyway
have a read yeah
so we wanted to before we start talking
about
food and diet on the microbiome we
wanted to talk a little bit about why we
missed
our podcast this last saturday yeah um
so we had a pet
get very very ill and we described
i described i don't remember what you
tweeted did you tweet i didn't say it
you didn't say anything specific so i
mentioned that we had a veterinary
uh emergency on our hands things did not
go
well and we ended up uh in the very
painful position of having to
um euthanize a a beloved pet
she was moxie it was one of our kitties
one of our kitties who you've seen
uh here on the set um and that is of
course
a very jarring experience for the whole
family including the other animals
jarring to the other animals as well
um and you know i you know it's going to
be a little while
before we even feel back to a normal
state of mind even though there's
obviously plenty of normalcy
uh even now in in every day it's
it's jarring i mean everyone who's had
pets and lost them knows
knows how awful it is but it um to those
who don't
they may think well it's an animal you
know what what's the big deal and
you know one of the reasons to have a
pet is because
you do share love but another thing
that makes it so impactful is that
uh this is someone with whom you live
every day
right and so um you know you miss
an animal who you've been living with
and interacting with
you know on an hourly basis especially
you know
you know after you know a year and a
half of hardly going anywhere um
very acutely uh there's just no
forgetting the fact that that she's gone
when you're at home and in this case
this is an animal we got as part of a
pair
and uh you know the other fairfax here
is
running around has been uh with his
companion
um you know they were in a cage together
for many months before we even adopted
them and so
incredibly uh tightly bonded and so
anyway it's been painful to watch him go
through it
but i wanted to say a couple things one
i don't really expect
other people to care about
the loss of a pet i do
expect them to understand the impact
that it has on people they pay attention
to and one of the things that really
caught me off guard
was the viciousness that i saw in
certain places
online when i said that we had a
veterinary emergency
there was disbelief that that was a true
story there was speculation about
whether or not
one or both of us had contracted covid
and might be
hiding it with such a story and i must
say this
is such a bleak indicator about where we
are the idea that people could have lost
touch with their humanity to the level
that they would
engage in such speculation even if they
privately worried about it to say such a
thing
is i don't know i find it i find it vile
so i would ask you if you know the
people watching
this podcast are unlikely to be
uh in that frame of mind but i do wonder
about the generalized loss of humanity
that is being induced by
the ways in which we interact online and
i hope people
all of us will take a step back and ask
ourselves
if something about that environment is
causing us to lose touch with
our most important capacities
maybe that's all that needs to be said
here but
um yeah um
i mean it's it's the more general
thing has been said many many times
before but people interact
online in ways that very few people
would in person
and one of the ways uh to try to return
to our better angels
i think is to ask yourself before you
engage
if this person were sitting right here
in front of you would you say this thing
that's true and i uh we have
a number of dedicated detractors
right people who reliably come after us
i must say i was looking into one of
them
weeks ago like long before this issue
had had cropped up
and i noticed that this detractor who i
really dislike i find his
critiques of us dishonest
but anyway i did notice that on his
social media
he described the loss of a
pet that had been with him for many many
years and it did remind me
that as much as i don't like the way
this person fights
that this was a human being right
now i would like to think i don't attack
people that way ever but it did cause
me to remember that even this person who
um i find
dismaying in their mode of interaction
has another side to their life
that i can relate to yeah absolutely
yeah all right um
let us switch gears we uh as
has become our want are working our way
chapter a week
uh through uh through our forthcoming
book which will be out in september a
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century
last week uh or in episode 87 we talked
about chapter four we read a brief very
brief excerpt from chapter four which
was
a chapter called medicine and this week
we're going to talk um
a bit about food and really you know as
the idea of this book in part was that
every single chapter could be one or
more books unto themselves
and certainly that is true um certainly
that is true for this chapter
and um this is this is a long excerpt
this week but i think um
i think it's all it's all relevant and
good this is actually the beginning of
the chapter and it's you know by no
means a majority of it but um it is a
long
excerpt so chapter five of a
hunter-gatherer's guide to the
21st century food what is the best diet
for humans
people have been preoccupied with this
question for a long time especially
weird
people many of us have tried diets that
are supposed to be what our ancestors
ate
but the lens with which we do this tends
to be reductionist and a
evolutionary at best from diets designed
to alter the ph of your body to those
based on your blood type to those that
restrict your intake to one or a few
kinds of food
like grapefruit or cabbage soup weird
people are both obsessed with and
confused by the question of what to eat
let's take just two diets that are
popular in some circles two that seem
less crazy than many
the raw diet and paleo those who
advocate for a raw diet suggest it is
the healthiest
most natural way to eat cooking they say
is a modern bastardization of the human
diet
this is simply wrong not only is cooking
ancient in the human lineage it also
allows us to get more calories from food
and while it may be true that cooking
can reduce some of the vitamins in the
food that has been cooked the benefits
far
outweigh this small cost people on
entirely raw food diets are often
undernourished especially if those diets
are also vegan
they are generally thin but that
thinness is not inherently healthy
others argue for the health of the
so-called paleo diet a diet free of
grains and most carbohydrates and high
in fat
this may well be a healthy diet for some
people
but those who came from lineages whose
cuisine is rich in carbohydrates
people from the northern mediterranean
for instance
may not be best served or most healthy
on such a diet
furthermore there is growing evidence
that early humans are eating a diet rich
in carbohydrates from starchy
underground vegetables
relatives of which include the african
wild potato as much as 170
000 years ago this suggests that while
healthy for some the paleo diet is not
particularly reflective of paleo ways of
life
these are only two of today's many
modern approaches to diet but they
reveal two similarly misguided
assumptions about food
first they imply that there is a fixed
and universal answer to the question of
what one should eat
just as we discussed with regard to
medicine the chances of this being true
are vanishingly small
differences in individual development
will render some foods healthy for one
person less so for her neighbor
demographics such as what sex you are
will affect what food is best for you
and the simple act of aging will change
the answer as well
cultural differences which are often
based in geography may well affect your
optimal diet
and those cultural differences may have
moved into the gene layer reflecting
population level genetic predispositions
to particular foods
as with the lactase persistence of
european pastoralists and saharan
bedouin
again remember the omega principle which
posits that expensive and long lasting
cultural traits like cuisine should be
presumed to be adaptive
and that adaptive elements of culture
are not independent of genes
the second misguided assumption that
many such diets reveal is that they seem
to presume that food is merely for
survival
the evolutionary truth is that food is
for more than just survival
food is more than nutrients vitamins and
calories
like all animals indeed all heterotrophs
we eat to acquire the energy and
nutrients necessary to be alive
but the human relationship with food
like that with sex has expanded beyond
its original purpose
humans no longer eat merely to satisfy
energetic requirements any more than we
have sex just to make babies
an historic and a historical
reductionist approach to diet attempts
to replace food with its component parts
take this supplement eat that bar drink
the contents of that can
you'll get x grams of protein a handful
of alphabetically named vitamins and
that rush of energy you've come to
expect
to get you through your day as is so
often the case such an approach creates
hyper novelty which then creates new
problems of its own problems that we are
too often defenseless against
the mistakes inherent in this approach
are many and the hubris abundant
the 20th century saw the dismantling of
chesterton's cuisine
as suggested by chesterton's fence we
ought to have understood what cuisine
was for before we took it apart
in its place we got easily quantified
and commodified pieces and parts that
can be added and subtracted on a whim by
the producers of processed food
instead of chasing the newest diet
advice with processed food now with more
b12
we should be eating real food real food
is that in which the base ingredients
are recognizable as coming from a living
organism
there are just a few exceptions like
salt
some things taste delicious and
flavorful to everyone rich and succulent
and salty and crispy and sweet and
smooth are combinations that are beloved
across cultures
our sense of taste evolved in an era
when meat and other fatty foods salt and
sugar were all rare
our sense of flavor is thus evolved and
important
this is true and it is true that our
sense of flavor can be and
is gamed in a system that can easily
create fat salt and sugar
and add them to any food stuff it wants
another manifestation of hyper novelty
fast food tastes good to many people
because it successfully games our sense
of taste
accessing single notes fatty salty sweet
in a reliable uniform way that can be
triggered any time you order the same
thing in any one of hundreds of
identical stores
by contrast a plate of carne asada rice
and beans with freshly made tortillas
pico de gallo
guacamole and pickled vegetables from a
local taco standard from your own
kitchen
will always be more nutritious and more
delicious too for many of us and for
anyone who chooses to develop a palette
that finds it so
that plate of less processed more
species diverse food is more nutritious
than a plate of fast food
just as it is more nutritious than
taking pills you're supposedly a match
for all the nutritional benefits you're
getting from your food
the whole is greater than the sum of its
parts
but why is the hole greater than the sum
of its parts or to put it another way
why is a holistic approach often better
than a reductionist one
two reasons first the parts of a given
system that we have turned into pills
are usually not descriptive of the whole
system
remember the discussion of vanillin a
component of vanilla and thc
a component of marijuana from the
previous chapter
second there is often emergence in the
combination of food in its less
processed form such that our bodies can
use food more effectively that it can
use pills
this is especially true for those foods
that have a long culinary history
together
such as the three sisters of corn beans
and squash traditionally eaten by
mesoamerican peoples
when these foods are eaten together they
constitute a complete protein
such a long culinary history points to
the human discovery usually unconscious
that just as smells good was a good
proxy for good for you until recently
so too was tastes good a good proxy for
good for you
reductionism in our approach to food
fails us as our bodies are not static
simple systems
nor do all individuals have the same
needs there is no universally best diet
for humans
there can't be in our varied
environments of evolutionary adaptedness
there were a few staples
in the andes quinoa and potatoes were
generally on the menu
in the fertile crescent of mesopotamia
wheat and olives were among the foods
domesticated early
in sub-saharan africa sorghum and guinea
yams were significant early agricultural
successes
there was meat sometimes in short-lived
abundance there was fruit seasonally
also in abundance
there was alcohol intermittently and
botanically created stimulants in some
places
in those places those stimulants were a
regular but low key part of life
even the ratio of macronutrients is not
stable between cultures
inuit have a high fat high protein diet
with almost no carbohydrates
which is unlike almost any diet that
evolved closer to the equator
given such variation the idea of a
universally best human diet seems
patently absurd
in the 21st century there are many
foodstuffs available that will trick you
into eating them even when parts of you
are sensing that it's a bad idea to do
so
before the advent of cheap always
available highly processed food our
ancient aesthetic preferences made a
very good guide to what to eat
those ancient aesthetic preferences
aren't so reliable now hypernovelty has
gamed our ancient rubrics about what to
eat and what not to and thus
we must use our consciousness to
separate the good from the bad
reductionism in our approach to food
also fails us and that it ignores food's
ability to provide connection to other
humans with the family and friends who
cooked for or with you or for whom you
cooked
a reductionist nutrient-centric approach
to food fails to allow for celebration
or for grief both of which are often
accomplished through food
it fails to recognize and remember
cultural tradition and to consider
flavors that have come together through
serendipity and experimentation
cuisines old and new reflect both their
terroir the land from which they emerged
and their borrowing from other cultures
and places those three sisters of corn
beans and squash are still dominant in
mexican cuisine
limes garlic and cheese all introduced
by the spanish to people in the new
world have been incorporated deliciously
as well humans do not just need protein
and potassium and vitamin c
we generally need those things in the
food context and what's in which our
ancestors ate them
we also need culture and connection when
we sit down to eat a meal together
especially when we are breaking bread
that we have ourselves made we gain far
more than calories
let us now look to our evolutionary
history how we ate and what we ate as a
way to understand how best we might feed
ourselves today
and that will be the next section
you know when i hear you read that
section i can almost
see why our critics see us as simpleton
grifter zealots i mean
kind of comes through in that section a
little a little yeah
all right um yeah that's uh
fantastic i i wonder i'm of course very
curious to know what other people
hear when they uh when they hear that
description
especially in light of the fact of it
uh not staking out a standard paleo
position
right um and obviously
making rational critiques of uh
current dietary fads yeah so i guess um
maybe before we riff on this a little
bit and before we get into some of the
other literature i wanna i wanna walk us
through today
um starting in chapter three of this
book and i haven't done it until now
we have at the end of each chapter
something that we call the corrective
lens
in which you know to the degree that
this is in fact a hunter-gatherer's
guide to the 21st century
we we give some some sort of operational
advice
on uh you know what you might do that is
apropos the
topic of the chapter at hand and so the
corrective lens section for the food
chapter is pretty long
but i thought i'd just share three of
the of the many more than that bullet
points from it and let's
um let's refund these let's see um
well we begin this corrective lens
section by saying we might call this
section the new kosher
most ancient dietary laws are now out of
date but that does not mean that we
couldn't use some rules around how what
and when to eat
avoid gmos gmos are neither inherently
dangerous nor inherently safe
they are however different from the
artificial selection that farmers have
been engaging in for thousands of years
when farmers chose choose plants or
animals to breed promoting some traits
and down regulating others they are
playing within the landscape that
selection has already been acting on
in contrast when scientists insert genes
or other genetic material into organisms
that have no recent history with those
genes
they are creating an entirely new
playing field sometimes they will be
lucky
and the result will be useful and kind
to humans sometimes they will not be
lucky
chimerical life forms that have been
created by humans using hyper novel
techniques are not inherently safe
anyone telling you otherwise is either
mistaken or lying to you
we also have um exposed children to a
diverse range
of whole foods especially ones that
connect them to your culinary and ethnic
background
eat the same food that you put in front
of them and show obvious enjoyment of it
keep seasonal produce on your counter
and let the children eat any fruit that
they find there encouraging them to
develop their own preferences while they
also learn how and when
to explore a variety of whole foods
and
do not forget that food is social
lubrication for humans
eating alone in your car after visiting
the drive-through is a novel situation
and it's not helping us connect with our
food our bodies and their needs
or one another i mean i think
that's one of probably the thing that
people will see coming the least
in this in this chapter most of which is
about the actual stuff that we should be
eating and preparing and
how to combine it and such and the
history of our doing so but
the fact of food not being just about
sustenance not just being about calories
and nutrients but actually about
you know one one of the ways that we
connect with one another and
see our way through not just celebration
and grief you know celebration and
mourning festivities
and and funerals uh but also just the
the daily cementing of bonds right the
the fact that you can come to rely if
you are
if you are lucky enough to live uh in a
loving family or in another situation
in which the people with whom you share
a living situation
come together reliably with food over
food that you have either made
or or brought in or or go out to
to find together that
those moments bring people together
uh in a way that's it's just easier i
think people have their guard down when
they're sharing good food
um and especially when it was prepared
by one or more of the people who are
who are sharing it yeah if you uh in
fact
had a list in front of you of the people
you know and the people with whom you
have broken bread
you would find that the broken bread
with list is a special list
almost inevitably yeah and maybe that's
um
you know at this point especially
especially since we're still you know
close to we're on the near
side of um having been effectively
forced into not interacting with people
not into into
basically no travel for so long that we
now know many people
um we feel like we know well but we've
never met
in person and the fact is upon meeting
in person
what you tend to do is break bread right
we tend to do that and that's not
it's not that we actually need to be
eating all the time we really don't
it's that that is a way to bond that is
an historic way to bond and
um nothing about the modern environment
should have changed that right and in
fact
if you if this was anything but the
modern environment
breaking bread with somebody would force
certain things that it no longer does
right you can break bread with somebody
where you've sourced
food from you know i don't know a good
restaurant or something like that
and so it still has the same symbolic
value but it's not the same thing as
uh cooking a meal for somebody you know
having them over and
thinking about what you know what you
might want to eat with them what you
know puts you and your
your family in their best light some
favorite meal or something like that
yeah
but i wanted to highlight something you
know there are a couple of
major themes in our book one of them
is this hyper novelty issue um
one of them is the synergy of the
various different
levels of analysis and then i think a
third one
um is the recognition
that we are stuck in this intermediate
state
where the ancient ways are not directly
applicable
the modern ways are almost universally
hazardous and one has to figure out how
to steer a rational course
that recovers as much of the ancestral
wisdom as is useful
and then rationally approaches the
topics on which one can't have a
traditional
view in some reasonable way and this is
sort of
mirrored by another phenomenon an
evolutionary phenomenon itself
which is everything i think this is
logically true
everything everything we might call an
adaptation
has some initial cause some problem that
it solved or opportunity that it opened
but many of these things especially in
the human context
nowhere more true than in the human
context many of these things
have picked up other values right so
uh you read this about you know sex not
being just about producing babies now
obviously
at the evolution of sex it was original
sex that's what it is
right and it really is that for
most creatures and then we get to a
small list of creatures for whom that's
not exactly true
right for whom there appears to be
augmentation and elaboration and a
basically a borrowing of that mechanism
for other things but it's really a tiny
handful of creatures it's a kind of
social glue
right and then in human beings we find
something
really utterly remarkable right which is
that
the primary purpose may in fact now be
in some sense secondary it's necessary
but the primary purpose may have to do
with um
you know bonding relationship
maintenance and not with direct
you know it's not that those two things
are inherently different obviously
in humans because the babies are so uh
labor intensive to raise well
a pair bonded uh couple or
more a pair bonded couple in the family
that they bring to the table
uh are you know necessary
to the proper raising of the children
and therefore the social bonding
phenomenon is reproductive in some very
uh indirect way but nonetheless more on
that in two three and four weeks
right those chapters yeah but but my
point is
okay so here you see it with food right
yeah actually but before you before you
go on i want to say that um
to some degree i think um the fact that
you know you've just posited that
perhaps
obviously the the you know the reason
for sex to exist
um as is is about reproduction
and um it's possible that in humans one
could understand that to actually have
become a secondary
a secondary function in many cases and
that would almost
have to have been true in order for the
level of confusion
that a lot of society now has over you
know what sex is and you know how
fundamental it is and whether or not you
can actually change what you are so
again
the sex and gender chapter is two
chapters from now and we'll talk about
it right fairly extensively but
but i think what i was getting at is
that this principle is actually
um so close to universal across the
important
things of of our modern human lives yeah
you know
i am struck by the fact that um
pets very definitely are
arose in human cultures
multiple times for reasons that were
practical
at first and we may not even know all of
the reasons we know
basically that uh cats arrived pretty
late
and that they did so because the
accumulation of grain
obviously produced a problem with
rodents and so
you know the sort of interesting
semi-wild creature that we now
uh bring into our homes was
you know semi-wild for a reason he
needed to do its wild rodent hunting
thing
near the grain stores and it's lovely
that it gets along with people and
doesn't attack human children and you
know all the things that you would want
it's helpful that they're diminutive
right but there's a reason that herding
cats
is the problem that it is which is their
initial utility didn't have anything to
do with them listening directions it had
to do with them following their
instincts over with the mice that were
eating the grain
and with dogs we have a very different
much more ancient story
where this was a hunting partner and the
basic point is you know this is a
collaborative hunting species
wolf right which is actually an
excellent hunting companion and
you know yes there's some story to be
told about how
uh wild wolves probably enjoyed greater
and greater proximity to people and how
they actually established a relationship
and no doubt
there was some situation where i don't
know a mother wolf was lost and the
puppies were just so adorable and
it happened that by hand raising them
all sorts of problems were solved but
interesting that both of these main
these main stories of our
of our domesticates um are about food
actually right
right about hunting and about
agriculture in the case of dogs and cats
respectively
right and actually dogs is the is the
outlier here as much as it feels like
hats is the outlier
well dogs are the outlier of all
domesticates okay
because it's the one that doesn't isn't
fundamentally about farming
right i think it is fair to say that all
of the other
major ones now there are cases where
things like parasitical
right it's not clear what that's about
right and it's an interesting question
um but in terms of i mean i guess i
guess it feels to me like by and large
we have two
two kinds of companion animals and so
there's there's there's animals that
are about uh animal husbandry and and
and we're basically breeding them for
for their meat or their wool or you know
they're they're good
right they're work animals with whom yes
we may come to
become fond of but they don't it's not
the same kind of relationship although
i mean i guess i guess horses um do end
up people do end up having that very
close relationship with horses as well
so okay i'll i'll accept your
you know it might i somewhat snarky an
outlier and out of two that's
that's not a thing but no i i see your
point the dogs we know
that dogs were domesticated a multiple
times
far more many years in the past yeah any
of the other much more like 30
000 years rather than all of the rest of
the domesticated which are like
less than 10 because of their
relationship to farming in one way or
another
um but my the punchline of this story i
think
is in the case of caps especially
they are now completely free their
reason for associating with us now has
precious little to do with mice and in
fact
well they can bring mice into the house
they can bring mice into the house they
couldn't find their way in
otherwise yes an occasional vole right
but
you know they you know as we become
socially disjointed
and we lose the connection to all of the
people that a normal human existence
would have us in contact with and then
we tenuously
explore ways of being connected with
people over the internet that actually
are simultaneously not satisfying
because they aren't like the original
thing and are getting better than they
were
right it is possible to have a real uh
bond with somebody over you know zoom
calls or whatever
right to develop a real friendship but
you know pets have taken on
an almost perfectly um
social um utility
to us that you know you establish to me
what this feels like
is really unusual
asymmetrical friendships right these
really are deep emotional connections
but you know what we get out of the
animals isn't the same thing that they
what
they get out of us you know except at
some very
you know thin edge right we get
emotional
sustenance from each other that's pretty
clear
but you know but the fact is having been
removed from their initial
utility to us is a little bit analogous
to
food having become you know much more
about the breaking bread and much less
about the providing enough calories to
get you through the you know the next 48
hours or
well this i mean this in fact is one of
the i think this is maybe exactly what
you were saying but um
one of the themes of humanity is that
we take things we take adaptations that
we're for a thing
and because we have the ability to adapt
so
rapidly and to create change in and of
itself that requires further rapid
adaptation
we you know for a whole slew of things
end up uh using adaptations that existed
for something else for entirely new
purposes right and so there was a big
stir
many years ago uh
stephen j gould coined the term
acceptation which is i was not gonna i
was not gonna name the thing well here's
go for it yeah
i wanna name it uh is that in fact at
some level the first time i encountered
that it's like well
you just named a category i don't i
don't know that we've got that exception
is going to be
something that evolved for one purpose
and then gets used for another purpose
so the modern thing that you're the the
new purpose that you're seeing it is an
acceptation not an adaptation in gould's
formulation uh because you know the
thing that is useful for now is not the
thing that was
it's raised on detroit right and i find
this to be an almost
nonsensical category because
you know the nature of everything is
going to be accepted
once you get a certain distance from the
origin of all of these things
and so you know like it's like
instantaneous adaptation and then
adaptation rather than adaptation and
acceptation
right exactly it falsely it basically
falsely corrals adaptation
to initial cause which of course is very
in keeping with
what i think is ghoul's biggest error
which is that he was constantly trying
to corral adaptation and sort
so he could shove things into other
categories um but anyway
you know long-standing viewers of this
podcast or the portal
will have heard the term telomere a
thousand times
um but this is a perfect example because
telomeres which are these repetitive
genetic sequences at the ends of
chromosomes
evolve at the beginning of eukaryotic
cells where chromosomes become
linear for the first time so before you
have eukaryotic cells you have circular
chromosomes which don't need a telomere
nor do they have a place for one
eukaryotes which have our eukaryotic
cells
have uh cell nuclei yeah and as part of
those cell nuclei then now
those nuclei encase linear
um genomes multiple linear chromosomes
and so
at first you have basically
single-celled eukaryotes
and then colonial single-celled
eukaryotes like yeast
right but in a yeast and they just start
collaborating collaborating
collaborating and
right and then at some point you get a
division of labor and you start to get
organismal stuff but
in that initial you know multicell
multicellular organisms would you say
i mean yeast is still an organism yeah
yeah yeah i mean multicellular
organismal stuff but but the point is in
a yeast
the telomere sticks
at a particular length its purpose is to
protect the end of the chromosome which
has problems if it's free-floating and
carries genetic information because it
triggers the repair circuitry and
bad things happen so you stick some
aglet on the end to protect it right
like you burn the nylon threads right
right it's like that but the point is
at that point you have a telomere
you've got the enzyme telomerase and the
enzyme telomerase is set to maintain
telomere length because there's no
purpose to anything else
at some point you get a really fancy
organism with
[Music]
vital organs and the ability to
self-repair
and now you've got a new hazard called
tumor
or cancer and then there becomes a
reason to have a telomere that actually
starts shrinking so
not shrinking was the original state of
these things and then turning it into a
counter
is a secondary adaptation that basically
takes a telomere whose purpose was
protecting the ends of chromosome and
turns it into a
a regulatory mechanism to prevent tumors
and
anyway yeah that's how all of this
evolutionary stuff looks yeah the
retooling is one of the
amazing powers of evolution and uh
mandating that it needs a different term
and isn't actually an adaptation
um actually just confuses the issue
quite a lot right and
um you know you will have heard in
several of the things that heather has
read from
our book uh indicates me yes they
sorry i should have looked them in the
eye i looked them in the eye when i said
that
but in several of the things that
heather has read you will have heard
reflections already
of the fact that humans have a very
special capacity
to upgrade software basically it's a
never-ending sequence of what gould
would call exceptions and what we would
call adaptations
that we self-generate yep
um cool well i mean we're let's
let's keep going um but also begin
talking about i've got three papers
um really two we're just gonna sort of
bundle together but uh three pairs to
talk about
and um you know none of them actually
had i run into at the point that we
submitted the final draft of our book so
that's you know that's one of the
both you know wonderful aspects of
continuing to be interested in what
you're thinking about in a manuscript
and also you know mildly frustrating but
of course it's just endless you know
there's there's a ton more that you can
discover at any
any time so
we have let me see if i can figure out
where it is let's just show my screen
for a second zachary here
this is a paper from 2009 by paul
clayton and judith robotham called how
the mid-victorians worked ate and died
published in the international journal
of environmental research and public
health
so i'm not going to if if i may
thank you um not
going to read from the top of it uh so
much but the basic premise
of this rather remarkable paper um and
the premise is
uh is well well borne out by
what they present the evidence they
present is that mid victorian era brits
which is basically between 1850 and 1880
and they say that the standard reckoning
is 1850 to 1870 but they explain why
they they take a slightly longer view so
these 30 years
the first 30 years in the second half of
the 19th century in britain
you know imagine for a moment this is
not in the paper but imagine for a
moment what you think
of when you think of you know a brit
living in this mediterranean era 1850 to
1880 for me anyway i think
dickensian right like this is i i think
i think of
any number of scenes from charles
dickens novels and it ain't pretty
you know these are these are sort of
people living out hobbes's
observation of lives that are um
solitary nasty british and short i think
i probably have those in the wrong order
but you know whatever hobbs
suggested that's it that's it um you
know of course he was talking about
humans absent civilization and hobbes a
couple hundred years earlier
i think um but that's sort of that's the
that's what we
imagine up at least i do when i'm
thinking of
that era but these authors from this
2009 paper again
called how the mid victorians worked
eight and died um
say that these these people were quote
healthier fitter and stronger than we
are
today their life spans and so i'm not
going to go through all the evidence i
will
i will um post this paper as always you
know links to these
all these papers in the show notes these
are
i think you know pretty easy to access
papers in terms of the language used
um their lifespans were equivalent to
ours actually
lifespans then declined around 1880
with the advent of mass agriculture and
processed foods especially tinned meats
and condensed milk and canned fruits
which had a lot of sugar in it
and basically globalization that allowed
things to be coming from far away but
preserved across
oceans and preserved with sugar
and salt in particular meant that we
went from an era in which lifespans were
almost
almost what they are today to the nadir
of lifespan in the modern era in 1900
and 1900 is the sort of comparison point
for many people who for instance will be
talking about
the ability to extend life endlessly to
say you know look at how much we've
we've added to life since 1900 well
maybe they don't know that they're
cheating but they're actually going from
the the low point the the short point in
terms of human lifespan in modernity
with 1900 so hold on yeah when you say
lifespan you are
undoubtedly talking about average
lifespan and there will have to be
there's one copy at least one caveat can
i guess yes of course
you know you're not guessing but no i'm
guessing okay based on uh
all the lifespan research that i've
encountered it would have to be
um i don't know what the
point would be probably one year it's
actually um well
that you have to make it to one year
before you get to
average lifespan there's a number of
ways to do the numbers but yeah
basically um infant mortality was very
high
and so you know as as they as they
discuss in this paper and and we'll get
to this a little bit but
um one of the actual truly major
advances of the 20th century
were improvements in in maternity care
in birthing outcomes and in
decreases in infant mortality rates so
yes
both babies and mothers died at a
remarkable rate
uh in you know in in that era such that
actually lifespans once you um
you know at once you got to either the
age of one or the age of five and five
is actually a safer number because there
were also a lot of
um communicable diseases that were
particularly that chil
very young children were particularly
susceptible to once you got to the age
of five
lifespan for both men and women was um
about what it is today with the
interesting caveat that for women it was
actually lower than for men
and that's because of the danger of
childbirth danger of childbirth right
which is actually a comparatively
late emerging hazard not completely but
a late emerging hazard
in humans i think comes with agriculture
right
um so you know many thousands of years
but um not many tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands of years
right but it's actually it's a great
indicator of
um the point you're making about
starting the clock on human longevity
at the turn of the 20th century right we
were at our sickest
and least long-lived right so in some
sense we all have the
wrong we all have several wrong ideas
that we carry around with us
about longevity one is that um in the
deeply ancestral past people you know 35
was old
and it's not true this number is heavily
dragged in that direction by
very substantial infant mortality um and
so
if you correct for that by saying
amongst people who live to a year or
amongst people who live to five years
what is the
longevity and yes indeed there were many
ways that you could die
relatively young so average lifespans
have gone up um
but maximum lifespans have not right
um and so and this infant mortality
thing is the same way we all have the
sense that
human babies are large their heads are
very big and they must be
born early and that this is all all
those things are true
they're born early in development
because of the size of their heads
but we extrapolate incorrectly that the
famous facts about the mortality of
mothers in childbirth are a permanent
feature of our bad design
rather than a novel alteration of
our circumstances after our design was
pretty good
agriculture made us more sedentary with
more reliable access to food throughout
the year
such that babies were born bigger and
fatter yep and bigger fatter babies are
more likely to have
trouble being born both for baby and for
mother yeah now some people remain fat
heads into adulthood
some do i've met some of them online
yeah i think you have i have two i think
um so advances in food processing things
like those tinned meats and the
condensed milk and the
and the canned fruit and such
promoted faster growth and so there you
know there's a whole lot
in you know in the media then and still
our understanding today of this era
of you know again the mid victorian era
because children were growing bigger and
fatter faster
um that it was imagine that oh these are
improvements
but adults were actually um you know
once the advent once around 1880 happen
and you started to get this
these new diets um being dominant yes
young children you know babies in utero
and young children were growing fatter
and faster
but adults were actually getting shorter
and life spans were
getting shorter and people were less
healthy
they were getting shorter more british
and in the early 21st century somewhat
more nasty
perhaps perhaps yeah um okay so i do
have one quote to read here you don't
have to show my screen zach from this
article from this paper
given that modern pharmaceutical
surgical anesthetic
scanning and other diagnostic
technologies were self-evidently
unavailable to the mid-victorians
their high life expectancy is very
striking and can only have been due to
their health-promoting lifestyle
but the implications of this new
understanding of the midvictorian period
are rather more profound
it shows that medical advances ally to
the pharmaceutical industry's output
have done little more than change the
manner of our dying
the victorians died rapidly of infection
and or trauma whereas we die slowly up
to generative disease
it reveals that with the exception of
family planning the vast edifice of 20th
century healthcare has not enabled us to
live longer
but has in the main merely supplied
methods of suppressing the symptoms of
degenerative diseases
which have emerged due to our failure to
maintain mid victorian nutritional
standards
above all it refutes the panglossian
optimism of the contemporary anti-aging
movement
whose protagonists use 1900 a nadir and
health and life expectancy trends
as their starting point to promote the
idea of endlessly increasing lifespan
these are the equivalent of the get rich
quick share pushers who insisted during
the dot-com boom
that we had at last escaped the
constraints of normal economics remember
this paper is written in 2009
some believed their own message of
eternal growth others use it to sell
junk bonds they knew were worthless
the parallels with today's vitamin pill
market are obvious but this also echoes
the way in which big pharma trumpets the
arrival of each new miracle drug
so um i mean that that seems apropos of
our moment
yeah rather a lot apropos of our moment
and it causes us to
rethink the victorians who may actually
have been
classy prudish and fort
fort meaning strong yeah yeah yeah all
right so got it got it
i feel proud of that i think nobody else
must have liked it based on the crickets
that i hear but
um yeah but you can't hear them that's
exactly why
yeah yeah i'm imposing crickets um okay
so let me just
walk through a little bit of what these
researchers
you want me to continue to don't you
just look at me like i i need to respond
to this classy british and fort is also
classy prudish and fort clasty classy
the victorians i mean just bring up some
victorians in your mind
yes if you know prudish is actually
accurate
you know it's one of those questions i i
uh recently did a
a deep dive on whether or not rubenesque
was ever
actually a a thing as far as sexiness
goes and it turns out that's more or
less a myth
really yeah that was just like one model
no it wasn't one models but it had to do
with the way models were
sourced for uh for nudes yeah
what i i now don't remember the logic
but
basically the idea was no nobody ever
thought that was so good but
um really right i mean it's a little
surprising
because uh because obviously you know
in an era when food isn't completely
reliable yeah um
having a little bit more fat on you uh
is you know
may make you more likely to survive the
next uh drought or famine no no
let's be clear okay okay first let's be
really freaking clear
okay there's what women's magazines
want you to think which is men want far
and
fl far later than reuben-esque i mean
right right no but that's ridiculously
thin and it's not what men
prefer right and then there's like
healthy levels of curvaceousness and
there's a
wide range of these things and then you
get on up to rubenesque
which we are told was the preference of
um of past eras and that these things
have shifted and the evidence is
actually pretty good that that's not the
case that it was a bia it was a it was a
what is the artistic equivalent of
survivor bias
i don't know the way the models are
apparently um i mean i guess i
i don't i don't know it's been a long
i'm no art historian i don't know but
um i mean i think even within just the
20th century
you know we see changes in what expected
you know optimal female body form are
according to the media
you know just by looking at you know
pictures of marilyn monroe
who you know everyone regarded as the
epitome of female beauty and she was not
real thin
at all yeah she wasn't and male
preferences don't land where
where we're told they're due they're due
english is not working for me so well
today but
um yeah okay so we'll we'll end up back
there
in a couple weeks for sure yeah um so
let's just um
a few things about the victorians in
terms of we've already i've talked about
what
changed around 1880 a little bit but um
what what did they do
well they um they moved a lot as part of
their working lives
uh they were the opposite of sedentary
such that actually their caloric
requirements were 150 to 200 percent of
what ours are today that we are
currently at an historic low as far as
we can tell in terms of what our caloric
needs are just to maintain ourselves
because we move so damned little
and um you know you can say this without
advocating for a work of hard labor
um but just recognize that the fact of
sitting
or standing or lying and you know doing
this
you know that's not very much exercise
the moving of the fingers
um on you know on your on your phone you
gotta type a lot
yeah it's really it's it's not major
muscle groups there
um so that's true um and then overall
they just had
like their diet was of lower caloric
density but higher nutrient density
so they had a lot of onions and greens
and roots
and fruits in season and of course
everything was organic and everything
was free range and this paper doesn't go
into you know it cites some things you
know the evidence for why that might be
better
but but there is a fair bit of evidence
for
why that might be better um you know
dried legumes are nuts
pickled fish you know fresh fish but
also pickled fish which is different
from having it tinned and being
preserved for you know many years
and being able to cross oceans uh even
the very poor
had in again 1850 to 1880 mid victorian
england had meat on a somewhat regular
basis the very poor didn't tend to get
the muscle
but they got you know they got other
parts of the animal i
i love the story about brisket
i think this one actually um is
perfectly emblematic of a sort of hidden
feature of
uh um culinary
so this is muscle but it's the you know
so muscle
is pretty much in every cuisine the
thing that people want the most and
all sorts of other parts of the animal
and no waste happens in times of of
anything but modernity
but within muscle so within uh preferred
and less preferred cuts
right and so brisket which is now a
fancy sought after cut
was a you know jewish immigrants for
example
uh it's obviously in black southern
barbecue
culture and the point about it is not
that there's anything wrong with brisket
in fact those of us who
like brisket tend to really like brisket
it's awesome but
what it is is so full of collagen
that in order to process it you can't do
it quickly right it takes a very long
slow cooking process to get it to be
that succulent delicious meat that we
know
and so the thing is if you're poor what
you tend to have
is labor to spare and so you can take a
couple of not money to spare
right you've got time exactly so you can
take a cut that is
disadvantaged by how much processing it
takes to eat it
and you can invest time into making it
really succulent and
anyway so it ends up in these um these
really
uh deep uh cuisines where there was more
labor than
than money well i would say i mean i
guess it's not just labor and i think i
think there's just two aspects to labor
there is
um you know there's is someone
available to do a lot of prep and
with with cuts that have a lot of
collagen
cuts of muscle that have a lot of
collagen between the fibers that require
a very long slow cook a braise or a slow
cooker or stew or something
you also need to have time wherein the
person could be working on other stuff
doing child care doing laundry when you
know the kinds of things that that
women usually would have been doing when
they weren't actively doing the prep
um but you not only need to have the
time to do the labor of the actual prep
but then the time to be around and
just like guard the fire like you can't
you would need to have someone who
didn't have to leave the house right
right and that's actually that's a
that's a huge
thing that you know the the rich didn't
necessarily
you know you know they imagine that they
didn't have the time for that
right they were too busy doing whatever
they were doing um
and it feels like there's there's a
bunch more to be said about these
oh i know um apparently also slow
cooking meat
under um so for long periods of time
under low heat
with with liquid so like in a braze or a
stew
produces far fewer of the now known to
be carcinogenic compounds
that high heat you know the kinds of
stuff that you know tastes great
when you grill it when you heat when you
cook under high heat fast
dry you tend to get these what is it
it's like
i have it here somewhere ages is what
the acronym is but i can't stand i can't
remember what it stands for
uh you tend to get more of those and
they are understood to be carcinogens
and so you know the slower the slower
cooking cuts
uh which people defaulted into out of
not having a choice
uh actually end up being healthier as
well interesting
yeah yeah uh so
let's see oh and i guess one other thing
and we you know we do talk a little bit
about
um beer in in the book as well but
apparently the midvictorians drank a lot
of beer
but it was of a lot much lower alcohol
content
than than it is than it tends to be
today and this you know this we know
also from
from the north american tradition um
that
especially when uh water might not be
safe because it might have cholera or
giardia
in it beer is effectively a way of
preserving
both some nutrients it's you know it's a
liquid loaf of bread it's preserving
nutrients
and it is preserving them in such a way
that you can get hydrated
safely because that that whole process
of fermentation
uh gets rid of things like cholera and
giardia yeah
and it does deliver a burst of nutrients
and you know the storage process is
the basis of so much of what uh cuisine
actually ends up being from you know
pickling to
canning all of these things are about
how you deal with a boom bust cycle
uh you know drawing of meat salting them
yeah it's all about boom bust cycle and
the point is it becomes
[Music]
the uh basis for cuisine
back to our earlier point right you you
take
something you know we talk uh in the
book about
the very special process of
spoiling foods in a good way so that
they don't spoil in a bad way that
basically you
team up with microorganisms fungi
or bacteria to cause dairy products to
spoil so that
you know milk that wouldn't last you
know would last a few days
uh unrefrigerated in its raw state can
be
preserved sometimes for months or more
and that this is you know these are all
basically hacks
to allow you to do things like live in
habitats where
not much is growing over the winter for
example
and the point is then these things
become the basis of cuisine and then we
start doing crazy stuff like
transporting them so that they you know
show up chaotically around the world
um and we don't know what to think about
them because we tend to come to this
the conclusion because of the way we
developmentally encounter
the foods of the world that it's all
just aesthetic oh those people like that
stuff and these people like that stuff
and i kind of like a little bit of
everything but the point is no those
were all coherent cuisines somewhere
and they were responses to the hazards
of
you know these different habitats and it
is nice that we can access all of them
but you know all of the ancient stuff
has an explanation for why it ended up
that
yeah no it's again those three sisters
you know squash corn and beans
were coherent and there was some
serendipity there and there was a lot of
human ingenuity there
and then you know the spaniards who
brought the new and the old world
into you know violent reconnection
but part of what happened also was that
the people
in the new world who survived it were
able to do a little cultural
appropriation
and pick up things like limes and and
cheese
and uh and you know what else was on
that list i can't remember but
um garlic oh
that was okay so zack says with garlic
um
i'm not sure that sounds right but um
and you know
and make a new a new synthetic cuisine
right now that's we should
we should expect that that's what
culture is that is that is what we do
is we uh as we bring the old and we
look for ways to make it fit with the
new environment and
every day is a new day every day is a
new environment at some level
right and you know what would italian
cuisine be without the tomato right
right exactly um also though you know
it's obvious
when you know an eggplant when you say
it out loud but
you know corns bean and squash right
that
combination was imbued with
mythological significance by people who
didn't
know what a protein was right right for
the
the knowledge about why this combination
is important is late emerging
the knowledge that it is important is
encoded into a whole different layer
and you can you know the crude
cartoonish way to think of it
is people who grouped these things had
an advantage over people who didn't
um and it had to do with them uh always
having
all the amino acids necessary to make
whatever proteins
they needed and so nobody needed to know
just as you didn't need to
know the germ theory of disease in order
to you know avoid
unsanitary behaviors you don't need to
know what a protein is in order to
establish a cuisine that completes them
that's right
so let me just read uh a couple
short excerpts from the end of this
paper before moving on to the next ones
um and i see i see we're already well
over an hour so
maybe i'll move through this more
quickly uh chap uh chapter five
section five of this paper is called
what did the victorians ever do for us
an homage i think to monty python um
the romans thus the authors write the
mid-victorian experience clearly shows
us that
one degenerative diseases are not caused
by old age the wear and tear hypothesis
but are driven in the main by chronic
malnutrition our low energy lifestyles
leave us depleted in anabolic and
anti-catabolic cofactors and this
imbalance is compounded by excessive
intakes of inflammatory compounds
the current epidemic of gene
degenerative disease is caused by
widespread pr
widespread problem of multiple micro and
phytonutrient depletion
and so i'm wondering what you'll have to
say about that and two
with the exception of family planning
and antibiotics the vast edifice of 20th
century healthcare has generated little
more than tools to suppress symptoms of
the
degenerative diseases which have emerged
due to our failure to maintain mid
victorian nutritional standards
uh and there's one more thing but why
don't you speak
i think there are two things overlapping
it's too much to say that wear and tear
is not the cause because wear and tear
is um
in one way unavoidably the cause and
it's not a cause in a simple
it has to be partially explanatory right
yeah and no nutritional supplementation
or
proper diet or anything can compensate
for it but what it does bring you to
dick alexander who was our friend and my
phd advisor and effectively
uh unofficial co-advisor
for you dick used to
he had he was he was a poet an amateur
poet
and there was this poem that he loved
the one
shay no i've forgotten who wrote it's a
fairly famous poem
and the idea is about this perfected
vehicle
um that's so good that instead of having
parts
fail it fails all at once which is
really the ideal
state biologically speaking what you
know when we have organ failure that's
one organ failing faster than the rest
the ideal state if you wanted to get to
the maximum
longevity which would be somewhere in
the neighborhood of 120 years for a
human being
a number that apparently has not moved
what it involves is everything failing
at exactly the ideal rate
the ideal minimal rate so that you know
you basically are young as long as
possible and then
you know the collapse is all all sudden
and at once and what we
what to the extent that that sentence
you order that
wrote that paragraph you read implies
that wear and tear isn't
a factor they're getting at some sort of
novel way that wear and tear happens
that is non-ideal
and just like with childbirth if you
were to look into the ancestral past
uh people would age you'd notice it
and in many ways they would age faster
because life was hard
but they would age more gracefully more
evenly
right what we do you know if you're
working in a mine
with a pick right you're you're
accelerating the aging of certain
joints right with that pick and that
means other parts of you may
you know be comparatively young and some
part of you is very old and
if you're you know if you're breathing
stuff in that mind your lungs will be
exceedingly old and you will basically
have a very uneven chaotic senescence
but
yep they conclude
do not therefore look to the drug
companies to provide remedies for the
appalling state of our health nor to our
politicians who seem unable in many
cases to see far beyond the brims of
their parliamentary troughs
look instead to the food and beverage
industries and to a lesser extent the
supplement companies
who may well step up to the plate with
better designed foods and nutritional
programs once the currently profound
counterproductive regulatory system has
been redrafted
so interesting that they do not they do
not reject supplements
out of hand they do not reject the
ability of the industries that are built
up around food and beverages
which have largely created the
epic mess that we are in today with
regard to the modern human diet
they say look to them it's not going to
be the drug companies it's not going to
be the politicians look for the people
who are actually making the stuff um
that you are eating and drinking like
that
that's they are the people who have the
capacity they are the that is the
industry that has the capacity to
actually
help us find our way out of this so
that's um
that's fascinating it is fascinating um
okay let's walk through a little bit of
let's see these two papers if i can find
them
okay zach you can show my screen i just
want to show
the two papers uh we have uh two papers
both written in 2015
uh one by logan at all called natural
environments ancestral diets and
microbial ecology
is there a modern paleo deficit disorder
part two this is in the journal of
physiological anthropology
and the second one oops is called
it's by the same first author and only
him alan logan
dysbiotic drift mental health
environmental gray space and
microbiota again in the journal of
physiological anthropology in 2015.
so these are um truly
remarkable and specifically with regard
to the second one
first the the title of the paper invokes
this word uh dysbiosis
he calls it dysbiotic drift so dysbiosis
is just
it's defined as like a perturbation to
the structure of the microbial
communities with which we live
uh and it's usually specifically
evoked to refer to perturbations
disruptions in our gut
microbiota in the microbiome in our gut
and as we've talked about here before
um you know the mainstream almost
everyone
until 20 30 40 years ago and i don't
know exactly when how many threads were
beginning to get on this bandwagon
um really imagined that you know
bacteria bad
you know we are singular beings and and
yes we now
know better but that of course raises
the question of how much we still don't
know
and so the the first of these two papers
actually walks through
a lot of um a lot of evidence that at
least
at least one important guy and a number
of people who were paying attention to
him
in the first part of the 20th century
the first in the middle part of the 20th
century were really talking a lot about
the need to have to have engagement
with the bacterial world out there in
nature
and uh you know and he actually was a
dubo i think is his name
actually came up with the first
plant-derived antibiotics
but you know as is as was often the case
i think with some of the most amazing
scientists in the first and middle part
of the 20th century
he quickly saw he quickly tracked what
might happen
if we started killing off all of our
bacterial communities and said you know
we got to be careful here there's this
reductionist approach
that puts us at risk if we simply try to
kill off everything because who's to say
that all of the things that are being
killed off are in fact bad for us
so dysbiosis which is what is referred
to in in
both these papers is is that it's a
disruption of
what is normal in our usually gut but
really any of our microbiome
and of course that raises the question
of what how would you know what normal
is
right what's what is normal um
and that that is
that is potentially a difficult question
to access we have evidence for instance
from
um the from some ancient
teeth um from the from which we can tell
what people were eating we have evidence
from pre-industrial a-industrial modern
people
and then we also have people who are
living who have
the most the most restricted
microbiomes who are therefore appearing
to be the most
dysbiotic the the most lacking in their
normal microbiomes
um gut microbiomes uh and these are
typically people who are economically
disadvantaged
living in urban spaces that are called
gray spaces this is not a term that i
i knew before gray spaces and gray
spaces are basically defined by a lack
of nature and abundance of manufactured
materials
gray spaces as most people listening
will you know
if you can immediately imagine up what
grace spaces might be you know they tend
to be food deserts
right they tend to be places where it's
very hard to get
uh whole food uh unprocessed food
uh produce of any sort you know the the
food that is available for purchase
tends to be
at uh convenience stores you know way
overpriced
and um not particularly good for you and
there is
um abundant evidence and i think we we
won't go through all of it here today
that eating that kind of diet is bad for
physical health and it's bad for mental
health
the thing that is new in these papers um
that that i am seeing
is that emerging evidence suggests that
the gray spaces are also
and this is this is my term here
microbiome deserts
that uh absent absent
nature and with a prevalence of
manufactured materials
on which the bacteria and and fungi and
such
that would be living within any green
space at all
these are effectively microbiome deserts
and you might say okay
who cares you know aren't there more
important things don't we need to get
fruit to these people right
but increasingly not just do we
understand that modern diets
have effects on physical health and
mental health
and and those things that are correlated
to
modern diets include you know all range
of things from major depression to
allergies to heart disease you know just
all sorts of things but so too
is dysbiosis now associated with these
maladies so dysbiosis again being the
a perturbation and what would be the
normal usually gut microbiome
so access to nature is also
more broadly linked to buffering of
stress and improved cognition and social
cohesion you know all of these things
are true but
specifically market shifts in intestinal
microbiota
that is dysbiosis are associated with
all of the following things
so you do not need to show my screen
here zach but um
this list is somewhat staggering
dysbiosis again disruptions in the
the gut microbiome are associated with
acute and cumulative psychological
stress environmental pollutants
crowding acoustic stress heat stress
westernized dietary patterns high
fructose high fructose and sodium
dietary age and food additives age is
advanced glycation end products
that you get via processed foods lack of
colorful dietary phytochemicals
so things like you get in colorful
produce
carrots and greens magnesium deficiency
inadequate omega-3
antibiotics excess alcohol um
oral pathogens when swallowed tobacco
exposure
sedentary behavior cir circadian
disruptions
sleep problems with functional
constipation low levels of vitamin d
and um almost certainly well this is
just slightly less
certain um the use of artificial
sweeteners
so these are things that tend to
accompany these
dip operate environments this is now
these are things that specifically are
understood to be and there's
just a ton of different references here
so in some cases it's understood to be
causal in some cases we only know
correlation
dysbiosis shows up with these things
associated with these things
yes okay and um and dysbiosis
is also um clearly
an effect of living in one of these gray
spaces
and so if you if you if you link those
things together
people who are economically
disadvantaged are living in urban spaces
with no access to nature no ability to
get their you know hands in the dirt
to to you know walk around barefoot and
get their feet in the dirt because there
is no dirt to be had it would be
dangerous anyway because it's not that
kind of environment
um are almost certainly dysbiotic
and hear all of the other things that if
you are dysbiotic you are also
at either higher risk to be or to have
or you
almost certainly already already are or
have these things
and um from there then it's you know
it's
it's an easy leap and you know again the
evidence is in this paper for you know
to
all of the very many known physical and
mental health effects
um that are related to um
uh to being to being dysbiotic
to being in one of these to living in
one of these gray spaces because you
have not had
uh you know because you are some
combination of of
unlucky and in and unable to get out of
it
and now you're dysbiotic and it's not
just the food
it's you know food desert is a really
striking term that i think most
most of our listeners will be familiar
with but the idea of a microbiome desert
because we can't see it
and because we don't actively choose
what what
you know for the most part how to have
our microbiome
it feels less important but um the
evidence is suggesting that it actually
may be
as important or more and further more
the sort of the reductionist approach
right is ah let's figure out if we can
give you a pill for that let's figure
out what probiotics you need
and just have you take it with your
morning whatever i don't actually i
don't even i think probiotics maybe you
shouldn't take with coffee or [ __ ]
i don't know um but that of course is
once again
this like let's let's take a feature of
the environment that we've completely
eradicated
find one thing in it that we think you
need and give you that
and what are the chances that's going to
be sufficient
yeah there's a a basic problem
of hubris relative to a complex system
where yes what is certainly going to be
true for any ancestor
is that they would have walked around
through the world
in equilibrium with respect to
these uh microscopic
symbionts and what that means is that to
the extent that there's an imbalance
it's a self-correcting one
how would it be self-corrected because
these things are all around us and so
they would have mechanisms that to the
extent that something has gotten out of
balance
would uh basically equilibrate and the
problem is if you live in an environment
where these things don't exist or worse
if your diet is um
is full of biotically
active stuff i'm thinking of
particularly things like preservatives
right a preservative wait you're saying
preservatives are biotically active
well in the following sense it's a kind
of ironic activity because what it does
is it shuts down
certain biotic processes but to the
extent that what your problem is
your business problem is is a the length
of the
supply chain for food right to the
extent that you need a potato chip to be
able to last six months
uh before it's actually purchased and
eaten you're trying to solve a problem
about
you know what if something got into the
bag and so you you stabilize it and the
point is that stability
is bound to interface in some novel way
with the processes by which we correctly
break these things down in order to
utilize them
and uh you know so and the problem
is that the environment that should make
these that should render these things
safe
is incapable of it right because how are
you ever going to know
if uh you know the preservatives in
the you know the baked goods that you
ate from you know the
the shop at the corner impacted you know
gave you a metabolic problem or a cancer
you won't know so you won't be able to
you'll never be able to
sue and so the point is as long as that
as long as the chain of causation is
complex enough and the delay
in the effect is long enough there's no
negative and the inputs are noisy enough
right abundant enough and therefore
noisy enough
therefore noisy enough the point is the
manufacturers only know of the problem
that they have to solve with respect to
getting the thing to still taste fresh
when you open the bag they don't know
nor necessarily care
about what happens to their customer
having consumed these things
they just want them to want to consume
more right and so in some sense the kind
of
um
i don't even know what to call it i'm
i'm trying not to dismiss it as
uh woo but the kind of sense of like oh
well i'm going to buy my stuff at the
farmer's market you know
obviously frees you from interactions
with all of the stuff that inherently
comes along with these longer
supply chains and the thing is liable to
be compounded by the fact that your
environment doesn't contain any of the
normal
elements that would allow an equilibrium
to correct for an imbalance that you
caused
with um you know food that's synthetic
so yeah it makes it makes sense to me
and i think if you know ultimately
maybe a hundred years from now we might
have a good accounting
of you know the sort of many
negative impacts of a large removal from
an
environment that looks anything like an
ancestral environment and it will
involve some very complex interplay
between the foods you ate and what uh
you know what bacteria you encountered
walking around and the basic problem is
okay yeah you're disrupting you're
disrupting many equilibria at once
and that is going to manifest in ill
health even if it's hard to predict
exactly which thing will cause what
phenomenon and that's
and that last bit is kind of the crux
because the people
the sort of the
techno utopians the coordinated
neocornucopians
will say what are you afraid of
like what's you know what's the risk can
you tell us what it is that we will lose
if we do this
and that onus actually isn't on those of
us who are saying
we can point to aspects of our
environment that we've been in for this
long and this long and this long and
this long and the longer
that thing that part of our environment
has been stable the more likely the
disruption of that aspect is
to um to be disruptive in some important
way and that's not you know sometimes
we'll get lucky sometimes it'll be fine
um just just like i expect gmos like
many of them will will be fine
probably and some of them will not so
i hope i hope i'm not going to get this
wrong but you can imagine
actually a uh
so skepticism is on the wrong side
basically what we've seen is a an
inversion of the correct burden of proof
you know people will be familiar with
the precautionary principle there will
be lots of pushback if we
say the precautionary principle with
you know any sort of reverent tone in
our voice because the practicality of
the precautionary principle in terms of
applying it is is actually a difficult
problem but
you can imagine some primitive version
of the same discussion before the
discovery of proteins and amino acids
and before the discovery of nitrogen
fixation and somebody saying well
which was the the great um in dust
techno-industrial
revelation of the early 20th century
that allowed us to suddenly
you know expand by maybe an order of
magnitude how much we could how much
food we get out of a uh uh
an acre of land or were you talking
about natural you're talking about the
haber bosch process
which allowed us to fix inorganic
nitrogen and bring it
but use energy from fossil fuels to fix
inorganic nitrogen which
created a huge amount of more protein
than we had access to so i jumped the
gun you were talking about like legumes
i was talking about corns beans and
squash and my basic point
well most only one of those things is
going to be the beans are going to fix
nitrogen exactly and so my point is
you've got two special things about this
group of creatures you grow them
together and it has an agricultural
effect that we only very late come to
understand
and it also has a nutritional effect
that we only very late come to
understand
in anything like mechanistic terms but
ancestors
figured this stuff out empirically right
they were growing these things why
because when you grow them together you
grow more of them and you don't starve
why because when you grow them together
and eat them together
you end up not having protein
deficiencies so
um how do these things taste good
because
they help you not starve that's why i
want those things exactly
so you can imagine some uh primitive
cornucopian arguing that actually we
could grow a lot more corns beans and
squash if you want by
you know separating them and you know
because very the
like joined harvest is complex and all
of that so
what if we just grow them in separate
fields right and suddenly you see your
corn and your squash harvest declining
after a few after a few harvests right
exactly and so
anyway i think it is it is worth having
in mind
that primitive skeptic that doesn't know
what they're up ending that we are now
in a position to say oh well here's the
reason that that's not going to work
um and realize that we are there we are
that we
we are there i mean this is this is this
is the hubris of maybe
humanity at every moment and the hubris
is always
particularly obvious at your current
moment it's like why do we think we've
arrived like why do we think we're at
that moment
where everything that we think we know
now is accurate and all the errors of
the past
are errors of the past and that was a
different kind of human but now we're
there like really you look around and
you think now we're here we've arrived
like we're those people right especially
biologically right if there's one system
where we're still
like taking baby steps it's
understanding the biological complexity
that we
are made of and faced with yeah and um
yeah that's a really bad place to make
this error and think that
you know we're in charge indeed um
so wow it's okay we've been at for a
while let's just
i'd like to do two very quick things um
just um bring it back
uh to covet a little bit um
in light of all that discussion about um
so effectively
i think i said at some point um we had
there were people
talking long before the hygiene
hypothesis was on the table the hygiene
hypothesis again
being um you sterilize your world you
you
you grow children in a landscape in
which you've cleaned
it too much and you are going to get a
rise in things like
autoimmune disorders and allergies and
things like that and there is at this
point abundant
support for the hygiene hypothesis and
so one might ask what are the possible
effects of all that cleaning and
sterilizing
that uh many of us were doing and um
some places are still doing
during covid when uh it was thought that
uh fomites were a a
and frequent mode of transmission well
there is
uh this paper zack you can show it
briefly
i chen it all published
published in august of this year um no
online it was published in april of this
year
um called biocide tolerance and
antibiotic resistance in community
environments and risk of direct
transfers to humans
unintended consequences of
community-wide surface disinfected
during cove at 19.
question mark and so i think you know
that's really all we need to
say about that that paper the paper is
what you would expect and it seems to be
well done
um but you know
basically of course just like
um too widespread uh
release of antibiotics creates
antibiotic resistance
just like the widespread rollout of
imperfect vaccines
potentially creates a selection pressure
for new variants that will then become
dominant
by over overly cleaning your environment
you will breed superbugs that are
resistant potentially to
um to the kinds of cleaning that you're
doing well there are two
factors one i agree that you know
too much cleaning creates a novelty uh
dip operate environment and that is
liable to have bad effects but there's
also a question about what you clean
with
yes and one of the reasons that i
strongly prefer and have strongly
preferred for a very long time as you
know it's almost been a joke around here
um cleaning with alcohol right
is that it doesn't it's not likely to
exert a strong selective effect what it
does
is has a very intensive effect and then
it evaporates away now
will that be perfectly safe i don't know
for one thing it evaporates into your
environment and so you do a certain
amount of breathing of it and so we also
have a strong bias around here
for having windows open so you know to
the extent that you might elevate the
amount of the stuff in your environment
it actually
dissipates out the windows at a higher
rate so you know you can start to think
about
how do i disrupt the environment least
given the cleaning that i i want to do
for whatever reason
but there's a very there's a big
difference between something that
uh intensively selects rather than
something that neutralizes a surface and
then allows it to be recolonized by the
normal bacteria and isn't selecting for
something specific
exactly and actually um you know vinegar
um
similarly yeah or even better yeah well
i mean i think they're you know
out who tend to use isopropyl alcohol
and then really
any vinegar will work but why go with
your you know nice vinegar when you
could just get you know cleaning vinegar
or use white vinegar whatever
um and they tend to work on different
kinds of things but both of those are
going to
do a good job on a particular thing and
then kind of you know disappear into the
environment and it's and it's fine when
they do
yep they don't um they don't continue to
side you know they don't continue to
dash cide
kill lots of things in their presence um
nor
do they um either remain in a form which
is toxic nor decay into toxic elements
yeah right um and then just one
one more thing i i have often brought up
this
um this issue um
that you know i look at the oregon
health authority's
uh covet emails whenever they come out
and i think a couple of weeks ago i said
i have yet to see
a you know i've yet to see in one of the
reports of deaths
that someone doesn't have underlying
conditions they
always say has underlying had underlying
conditions or
the presence of underlying conditions is
being confirmed now since i said that
i have i did see one i did see one
uh so that's um that's news
i guess but i also found
this paper zach if you will this is
actually on the cdc site
called underlying medical conditions and
severe illness among 540
667 adults hospitalized with cobin 19
and the data are between march 2020 and
march 2021
and so what it what it finds if i may
have my screen back zach thank you
what it finds is that 90 and that's a
that's a year that's a year's data
of over half a million adults who were
who are hospitalized right so this isn't
all cases this is hospitalized adults
94.9 of hospitalized patients had
pre-existing conditions
94.9 percent and specifically the big
risks biggest risk has
the biggest risk factors for death that
they found were obesity
anxiety and fear-related disorders
diabetes with complication
and then also the total number of
conditions
the more of these uh risk factors you
had the more likely you were
to die but um that's a that's a
remarkable list
to me yeah i find the anxiety disorder
is particularly interesting
yeah how would that be playing in and i
don't i
don't have an answer yeah i mean i could
see a couple possibilities it could be
something
about what we do with anxiety disorders
it could be you know medications that we
apply
uh render you vulnerable could also be
something about a positive feedback
you know to the extent that we see uh
numerous uh circulatory disorders
i would imagine as you get very sick
with this it's gonna trigger anxiety and
if you have an anxiety disorder it might
be an extreme
form but um yeah that is that is
fascinating
it is remarkable and as you've pointed
out many times it's
weird and obviously medically
counterproductive that there is some
stigma to discussing
the just simple fact that these
other conditions impact how seriously
covid
is likely to affect a person yeah
because it's actually something in which
there's
a lot people can do exactly and you know
i haven't heard as much about it lately
but um especially last summer there was
a lot of talk
about uh racial disparities and coveted
outcomes yeah
and um there's some you know there's
some thought about it being related to
vitamin d production yep
right um but there's also you know
almost never mentioned the conflation of
race and class
that because of yes historic systemic
racism
uh black people at least in america are
more likely to live
in um underprivileged circumstances in
these great these gray spaces exactly
the kinds of spaces that we were talking
about before
which are both food deserts and
microbiome deserts and if you're in a
microbiome desert and you therefore
already are at risk for all of these
other risk factors
yeah um then you are more likely also
presumably to get covered yeah
uh so you know it it is there
an explicit racial component there might
well be having to do
uh with melanin content of your skin and
um and a lesser ability to synthesize
vitamin d
but i think far too often there's a race
class
um sort of erosion of of pattern and
that we should be talking more about
class and
um and and helping people actually be
able to get you know the food in the
microbiome
um that is a better match for for what
they might have been eating and being
exposed to
pre-industrially well i think there's
also you know
we are entitled to know in what ways
we are advantaged and disadvantaged and
to the extent
that you know one doesn't necessarily
realize
that the circumstances where one lives
or the food that's available there or
the length of the supply chain
to uh to source food in the first place
has impacts on human health we have a
right to start tracking this
right right yes if you want to equalize
something
meaningful this would be a good place to
start
absolutely absolutely
um well it seems to me that we should
have a nice food thumbnail for today but
that's um that's the image that i
that i tweeted out um and uh we could at
least show it because some people wanted
to
i wanted to know what this was so zach i
don't know if this will be out there
our thumbnail but this is
this is the twalton river which flows
into the willamette
um both the rivers that i've been uh
paddleboarding on of late
and so you don't walk on water you stand
on water
i stand on one put yourself across it
yeah yeah i i use an
ore either yeah or
yeah uh but this this
this is the pacific northwest in the
summer right here and one and
i guess you know we never we never went
personal on food
in this conversation but i like brisket
goodness yeah you did you did you did
you did do that but
um summertime in the pacific northwest
in the willamette river valley
the the fruit that is being produced in
this part of the world right now is
just extraordinary and and the greens
and the you know
and everything else that's coming out of
the ground but um really it's berries
now and stone fruit
and uh you know you eat it while you
can't eat it while it's local yes
now that we're on the subject yesterday
you took us to a
place on the river that you have been
frequenting and uh
toby and i swam across not expecting to
find a bonanza on the other side but
there was a
there was a massive blackberry bush that
was
just not being accessed by people or for
some reason
birds and we had ourselves a little
blackberry feast so and we also found
some
um all of us on the way there and you
know there's just nothing like a
sun-kissed blackberry in the
mid-afternoon and the summer sun eating
it fresh off the vine there's nothing
like it i actually paddled past that
place this morning when i was out
um it was a different yeah it was early
and it was gray out yet
um and there were actually two turkey
vultures there
hanging out i don't know if they were
defending the space or or
or what but uh they were they were
sitting right there yeah when uh
toby and i was quite a swim across and
as we approached there was a turkey
vulture
popped out of nowhere standing on a rock
looking they're not the handsomest birds
i i have
trouble trouble relating to them or
maybe i should relate to them well but
yeah it's not the handsomest bird um but
anyway so you'll be interested all right
i liked your proposed thumbnail might be
better than mine but uh without us
having discussed it zach do you want to
show the thing that i sent as a possible
thumbnail
oh it's paddle board is on the
willamette nice
so that's not anyone we know but you
took that at some point
you took that from a bike you must must
have yeah i took that drone
uh that was from the bike path uh over
at oak's bottom
that's great yeah so that uh you know
again
um well we'll end with the usual way
that we sign off but is it time to
to do our sort of announcements and uh
yeah i think i think we have arrived
there
all right so we are going to take a
15-minute break
and then be back with our live q a uh we
will be back with
episode in livestream 89 uh in which in
part we'll be talking about chapter six
which is on sleep
next saturday um
but in the meantime uh you can ask
questions at
i forgot to put it there at
[Music]
darkhorsesubmissions.com
uh and there are instructions facts
there uh consider joining
my patreon uh the monthly private q a is
this sunday consider joining brett's
patreon
your monthly conversations will be
not this weekend but the following
weekend at both of our patreons you get
access to our discord server
you can ask logistical questions but not
questions for a q a
of our moderator at darkhorse.moderator
gmail.com
you can get darkhorse shirts and goliath
shirts and such
at store.darkhorsepodcast.org and wear
them where
where you will encounter someone who
deserves to be annoyed by them
absolutely i don't know where that would
be exactly but outside google
headquarters
yeah if you happen to live you know san
jose or environs
in california and consider subscribing
to all four of our channels at this
point we've got two on youtube two on
odyssey
brett weinstein's main channel on both
and then dark horse podcast clips
on on both and you'll like the video
share the video and
remember to be good to the ones you love
and eat good food and get outside
be well everybody
you